hello friends i'm alana and welcome to
my channel uh i thought i should just
make this quick
video before bed let's just ignore the
fact that this
this jumper which is very cool what up
is half see-through because
i guess it's too green for my green
screen i think it looks cool i'm into it
whatever don't worry about it
but basically i realized that i always
uh post stuff like this on instagram and
never on youtube despite the fact that
youtube would be the place
where you would see the content so here
i am i
also maybe just want to talk about it
because i'm very excited about it you
thought about that
basically i'm getting to play cyberpunk
2077 tomorrow
i'm very excited and i'm going to be
making another one of my
preview type videos that i basically
always make where i let you guys ask as
many questions as you want to
and then i will answer as many of them
as i can literally that's how i do it is
every single question that i can answer
because i've seen that part of the game
or whatever
i will answer unless i have just
absolutely no interesting
answer to it so there's nothing off
limits at all um i'm getting to play i
think three or four hours of the game so
it is a solid chunk of gameplay i
believe some people
got to play today the embargo is the
25th so we get to talk about our
impressions on the 25th and just
generally
i can't wait full disclosure
i'm absolutely biased where this game is
concerned you can't say i didn't warn
you i'm really excited by virtue of
having worked in the industry for a long
time i feel like at some point i stopped
being like inherently
excited about video games i love video
games trailers make me cry i've said
this on multiple occasions there are
multiple videos of me crying at video
game trailers
but i mostly get like curious about game
releases
it is uncommon that i
let my expectations get super out of
control and i get way too hyped
probably because it's a bad idea nobody
should get over-hyped about stuff
just it's just you setting yourself up
for failure while you're at it stop
pre-ordering video games kids
i'll say it again i've said it before
i'll say it again
but um i am really excited about
cyberpunk
uh so while i will answer
any questions i can as objectively as
possible it is totally worth noting
i'm really excited about this game
i think i'm having trouble going to bed
tonight
because i know that i get to play it
tomorrow
i did also want to take this opportunity
to address because it has confused some
people
so if you didn't see the news cyberpunk
got delayed it got delayed from
september to november i think it's
november 17th or 19th
17th 19th 17th basically for a reason
that i'm always in
massive support of uh which is
they need more time to polish the thing
they need the game to be better
it sounds like all the base systems are
completed but uh
yeah they're adding more time for polish
because they want to give you
a good video game not a okay video game
that is then patched for several years
because that's [ __ ]
and we shouldn't be accepting that from
companies in any case so very in support
of them delaying it
always in supportive studios taking
their time on products even if i'm very
excited about them as i am in this case
but because of the delay people are a
little bit confused about
why they've dropped previews this week
and i think that's just like kind of a
misunderstanding of how previews work in
a lot of cases
a preview is not the completed game i am
not getting to download the game
and just have it preview builds are
usually
either selected from the part of the
game that functions at the time
and that is usually publisher pressure
related so like if if the
the marketing team is like we want
people to be playing it at this point
then you just pick the point of the game
that is actually playable
or and this is why previews are often so
positive
you pick a chunk of the game that you
understand is
the best or most polished i don't know
which of those it is for
cyberpunk but them releasing a preview
build does not in any way really relate
to the fact that the game was delayed
it's not like it basically just means
they had a chunk
that they're allowing press and a few uh
influencers or youtubers i believe to
play
and marketing and pr teams are the one
focusing on their energies on that the
dev teams are still
obviously developing the rest of the
game and probably i'll even see some
bugs tomorrow potentially
i don't know we'll see maybe that part
is completely polished i genuinely don't
know
but basically the two are unrelated and
and i don't think anyone should be
taking it as a slight the preview builds
are going out but not many people are
getting access to it so
ask me as many questions as you like i
will talk about it in
uh absolutely as much detail as i can
there aren't any
restrictions i'm allowed to talk about
absolutely everything that i play
so i'll do a q a and then i might also
do um one of my gameplay talk throughs i
think that's going to be a little bit
harder because
i don't really want to stop to take a
lot of notes i want to just play
uh for anyone who hasn't seen my
gameplay talkthroughs uh yeah like this
kind of thing if i get to play a game
early i literally talk through what
happened instead of a walkthrough it is
a talk through
because i'm not allowed to capture any
gameplay but yes that's enough for me i
don't need to make this video any longer
i just wanted to say if you guys have
questions
let me know i just also wanted to give a
shout out to this pimple on my cheek
just showed up right here you know i got
ready for bed
i took my makeup off when i put some
moisturizer on and then
noticed that guys showed up on my face
today so lucky me i got a new friend
all right that's it really excited
i can't wait i want this [ __ ] game so
bad
i know a lot of people do i know a lot
of you feel that way
i will try to share this with you as
thoroughly
as possible have a good night if you are
watching this at the time that i upload
it which is probably about 1am
i'll see you guys soon bye